[Music]
you guys I'm planning for your death
what what yes no me too actually a
little bit attachment kind of actually
because we are talking about what am I
on the virus get it today so there's
this website not sponsored but this
website called Lantern is helping people
tackle the complex logistics of either
losing someone or just preparing for
your own death and like just getting
things done like they offer a free
checklist for you to check out and it's
to just kind of make it's like prepare
for your death more of a positive
experience this is good marketing like
that yeah their Instagram page they
wrote the death rate is 100% plan ahead
so mmm yeah I mean it's just a tool that
is just helping a lot of especially
Millennials cuz you know we love simple
things we love things we love doing
things online ordering our food and all
this stuff so we can at least prepare
for our kind of life yeah have you heard
that the human mortality rates about to
go way up because of current scientific
advancement mm-hmm like yeah if you're
like lifespan or more if you're like in
your give you're under 25 you you your
life expectancy is now like a hundred 25
or so like that 120 I do not want to
because of quality of life is about to
go away the Pago diseases all kinds of
[ __ ] it's about to get way better for
you mm-hmm so uh yeah I think I'm gonna
put it off unless unless you can still
be agile I like 118 yeah but when you're
like okay it's a 1,700 right and you're
[ __ ] 60 that's us but if you're if
it's now and you're 60 it's not as bad
you guys gonna figure out jobs that
people can do until 120 cuz legs take
care of me you gotta [ __ ] rope it do
it look like that [ __ ] you know that
wheelchair worm in spongebob love that
character I do love having you know the
thing about it that's interesting for me
is because like a hundred years ago if
you were to tell people like yeah over
in this country people live to be a
hundred years old a baby like that's
absolute [ __ ] but in another hundred
years people are going to live to be a
hundred and fifty years old no [ __ ]
problem like literally no problem and
for me that's just like insane can you
imagine seeing a hundred and fifty years
of history and advancement life
expectancy used to be 40 years old and
[ __ ] man I mean just now like the fact
that like I'm 30 and then few centuries
ago yeah and the majority of people have
poor eyesight and the fact that they can
get a fixed or they have glasses
that's like survival you cure the blind
now and we're you're away from hearing
all blindness like all of it oh thank
god cuz that's like my biggest fear
silence okay what will be what would you
choose rather to be deaf or blind yes I
don't like that question well right now
I would choose to be blind because in
your way it's not that not that normal I
would do blind and you'll never see your
babies again yeah [ __ ] kids raishin what
if you could never see titties again
come on Charles can you feel this
hey Villa you could feel okay but what
if you're not feeling I'm what if you're
feeling mousepads
you know the difference it's a warm I
already can see like 13-year old Steve
listen man I got everything ready to go
cuz you need someone or something just
like help you around when you're blind
like way fun yeah yeah [ __ ] it like you
can feel vibrations and music so you can
still experience right now and then I
just be friends with every deaf person
ever because we all speak the same
language hey dude I saw a blind guy at
the gym the other day and I was like
what's the new year brothers and he was
a
[Laughter]
I mean losing their mean music and like
filling the vibrations is completely
different from hearing I don't like
music that much really well I like quiet
I like quiet every time he borrows my
car I get in there and it's the AM radio
that's on my ears I prefer NPR's yeah I
just prefer to hear what's going on
especially lately
sorry old no I like music but I like me
to that [ __ ] touches you the [ __ ]
gets in your soul
Motown don't we talking about well we're
at this trash - [ __ ] Lana Del Rey's
[ __ ] cool I mean I don't really get that
in Nicki's car so Eminem because you
won't listen look you only does not
[ __ ] even have can we do something
know what this morning you said no you
said no rap so I put on my mellow ass
playlist it was to mellow like music
unless it's like he has four songs on
his iPhone well that's not my designs
Prince's Purple Rain yeah [ __ ] you like
some The White Stripes or something well
I had that song it was an army well it
was known as I have I hear the song that
I have other than Barbara rain was was
because of a [ __ ] Instagram story
that I did years ago yeah well no I just
downloaded it for the [ __ ] thing yeah
just think about if you're deaf you can
ignore people right like I do dude once
that was definitely ear and when you got
like annoy to my ass we'll just give me
his deaf ear and he'll lay down on this
one yeah
turn off your [ __ ] I mean they like
when you're blind nobody wants to like
engaged in the conversations they do
people like are weirded out by public
affection and also handicapped and
homeless that's why people always tell
you see people think into the highway be
like you see blind people you like get
out of their way like nobody's gonna go
out a way to have a conversation which
you need the one that else attire you
can be able to see people interact I
like to observe people as what what are
you doing is my favorite thing to see if
I already in like kind of a hermit so I
like I like to sit alone he looked at
people watch a frustrated husband listen
to [ __ ] me that
but that's Boreas fine your car then AM
radio well that or Motown I like [ __ ]
mic didn't so see you pigs out I like
some old [ __ ] man I like I like the
oldies I like oldies - that's we can
play olders all day that's not
weightless if you don't play it very
much AM radio clam in a molten zone no
that's not true
I play oldies if you ask that's true
Eminem songs in the past three hours in
between a lot more than that you just
haven't been listening it's been too
much it's a lot because I just got this
new game where you it's like a it's like
a rhythm game and they have a lot of
Eminem on there so I just been you've
been rappin you've been rapping hard
back to my original question do any of
you guys have anything set up for when
you're gone so like for me yeah I don't
know what it's called what is state yeah
the contingency setup for like if all
your jet planes go estate oh we keep we
keep it in the family
where's your ensuite garden who's that
go to it depends I hope if the mansion
oh I see yeah which mansion well there's
one out here there's also one in the
Hamptons but that's more like a family
thing like a summer home hundred bucks
in like half my chicken to give my
sister if anything I have I said I set
my beneficiary as my sister so
everything goes to her yeah do you have
a contingency set up so if she's not
available like somebody else no bury me
with my [ __ ] I'll go [ __ ] no one gets
[ __ ] for me but yeah they're gonna bury
came in 10 set are you gonna get buried
no when I get cremated some just burn
all my [ __ ] - married or buried buried
oh I heard married I heard married do
and then I was like excited for your
wedding but okay like if I go to the
cream what if you're afraid of being
babe but you're also afraid of being
burned yeah oh there's other solutions
they have a ton now oh they can turning
it to try in three
Oh what I'm into legal tender today oh
I'm gonna turn to a treat and then even
after I die
what do you guys yeah you know what
actually [ __ ] all y'all freeze me I'm
trying to come back yeah yeah I'm coming
I wanna go back honestly hunter I'm
tired now thank you plus there's other
planets you know you drink oh no sir I'm
coming back so I could pee and [ __ ] on
the graves of my enemies coming back you
won't know anybody you started from zero
or find them everybody's dead that you
know right you have to start from zero
in this new time and figure out how to
make it like a dollar
Oh even if that's still the same time
they would have the cryogenics
reanimation programs where you become
friends with other Rhian frozen people
and they set you up with work to here
I'm going to set you novel start I will
make sure that my granddaughter starts
that agency because I'm coming back and
I'm coming back with the job
40 years old stored at the [ __ ] grand
to here I'm going to wake up in the year
3020 - yeah I'm going to go to a
7-eleven and I Rebecca excuse me I'm
looking to [ __ ] on the graves of my
enemies do you guys still sell those
burritos as big breathe that point
they're gonna be able to take some of
our DNA and grow us oh that's time yeah
reincarnate like I always do well wait
what if they're gonna clone us and then
we put our brains in our own younger
bomb oh I would love that
I want that I want somebody loan my body
like I want to be like hot 40 what
important what if the young becomes a
race in itself where like people can
tell he was actually young and who's
faking well be like I didn't know she
wasn't actually young weird I mean a
movie big do you think that's like his
some form of pedophilia oh yeah he [ __ ]
a jacket for sure Tom Hanks when he was
like [ __ ] sorry a 40 year old man money
and he makes a wish that he wishes in
his bed hey movie at the time but
there's so many movies daughter daughter
born
time to watch with her a couple weeks
ago and I did a little sexy and she was
like wait she just did it with a kid I
was like well no no he's a grown-up
she's like nobody's a kid I was like I
mean but he's he has grown body she's
like that's pedophilia I'm like you know
what get the [ __ ] out you tried to watch
blank check lately no I haven't seen
that the end of that movie this kid
who's literally [ __ ] 13 years old
Preston wherever the [ __ ] kisses the
bank lady who's 30 he kisses her on the
lips she kisses him and they're sitting
by a fountain and they kiss [ __ ]
collision is the thing that Blake tech
is like I was like a million dollars -
right yeah yeah it's not a lot of money
now be lucky to get $800,000 that's it
he'd be lucky to get six under the eyes
was he right smile [ __ ] is riding around
with a limo NSYNC [ __ ] you think you
want the castle and the castle is in LA
yeah right yeah right look at the [ __ ]
out of here go get your ass about a San
Bernardino so whatever the [ __ ] you
might have been at for real never do you
can afford that
yes he's lucky driving a Ford Taurus
yeah
[Music]